you were a proponent of deep learning
before gained widespread acceptance what
did you see in this field that gave you
confidence what was your thinking
process like in that first decade of the
I don't know what that's called 2000s
the arts yeah I can tell you the thing
we got wrong with the thing we got right
the thing we really got wrong was the
importance of the ER the importance of
unsupervised learning so early days of
Google brain we put a lot of effort into
unsupervised learning rather than
supervised learning and there was
argument I think was around them 2005
after a near Europe's
at that time called nips but now in
Europe said ended and Jeff Fenton and I
were sitting in the cafeteria outside
you know the conference we had lunch
with his chatting and Jeff pull up this
napkin he started sketching this
argument on a on a napkin but it was
very compelling is our repeated human
brain has about a hundred trillion so
there's 10 to the 14 synaptic
connections you will live about 10 to
the 9 seconds that's 30 years you
actually lived for 2 to 2 by 10 to 9
maybe 3 by 10 to 9 seconds so just let's
say 10 to 9 so if each synaptic
connection each weight in your brains
neural network has just a 1 bit
parameter that's 10 to the 14 bits you
need to learn in up to 10 to 9 seconds
of your life
so by this simple argument which is a
lot of problems it's very simplified
that's 10 to the 5 bits per second you
need to learn in your life and I have a
one-year-old daughter I am NOT pointing
out 10 to 5 bits per second of labels to
her so and now I think I'm a very loving
parent but I'm just not gonna do that
so from this you know very crude
definitely problematic argument there's
just no way that most of what we know is
through supervised learning but why she
gets so many visit information is from
sucking in images audio those
experiences in the world and so that
arguments and there'll all of known
forces argument neovision go going to
really convince me that there's a lot of
power to unsupervised learning
so that was the part that we actually
maybe maybe gone wrong I still think I
was learning is really important but we
but then in the early days you know
10-15 years ago and all of us start down
with the path forward oh so you're
saying that that that perhaps was the
wrong intuition for the time for the
time that that was the part we got wrong
the part we got right was the importance
of scale so Adam Coates
another wonderful person fortunate worth
of him he was in my group at Stanford at
the time and Adam had run these
experiments at Stanford showing that the
bigger we train a learning algorithm the
better is performance and it was based
on that it was a graph that had been
generated you know where the x-axis
y-axis lines going up into the right so
big a make this thing the best
performance accuracy is the vertical
axis so it's really based on that chart
that Adam generated that he gave me the
conviction that you could scale these
models way bigger than what we could on
the few CPUs we should understand that
then we could get even better results
and it was really based on that one
figure that Adam generated that gave me
the conviction to go of Sebastian Thrun
to pitch you know starting starting a
project at Google which became the
cuckoo brain crunch brain you go file in
Google brain and there the intuition was
scale will bring performance for the
system so we should chase a larger and
larger scale and I think people don't
don't realize how how groundbreaking of
it is simple but it's a groundbreaking
idea that bigger data sets will result
in better performance it was cultural
fit it was controversial at the time
some of my well-meaning friends you know
senior people in the machine learning
community I won't name but whose people
sold people of some some of whom we know
my well-meaning friends came and we're
trying to give me friendly meze hey
Andrew why are you doing this is crazy
it's in the near enough architecture
look at these architectures of building
you just don't go for scale like this is
bad career move so so my well-meaning
friends you know we trying to some of
them were trying to talk me out of it
if I find it if you want to make a
breakthrough you sometimes have to have
conviction and do something before as
popular since that lets you have a
bigger impact let me ask you just a
small tangent on that topic I find
myself arguing with people saying that
greater scale especially in the context
of active learning so it's very
carefully selecting the data set but
growing the scale of the data set is
going to lead to even further
breakthroughs in deep learning and
there's currently pushback at that idea
that larger data sets are no longer that
so you want to increase the efficiency
of learning you want to make better
learning mechanisms and I personally
believe that bigger data sets will still
with the same learning methods we have
now will result in better performance
what's your intuition at this time on
those I Anna this dual side is do we
need to come up with better
architectures for learning or can we
just get bigger better data sets that
will improve performance I think both
are important and there's also problem
dependent so for a few data sets we may
be approaching you know Bayes error rate
of approaching or surpassing human level
performance and then there's that
theoretical ceiling that we will never
surpass so Bayes error rate but then I
think that plenty of problems where
we're we're still quite far from either
human level performance all from Bayes
error rate and bigger data says with new
networks but without further African
innovation will be sufficient to take us
further but on the flip side if we look
at the recent breakthroughs using you
know transforming networks or language
models it was a combination of novel
architecture but also scale had a lot to
do with it if we look at what happens
with new ep2 and birds
I think scale was a large part of the
story yeah that's that's not often
talked about is the scale of the data
set it was trained on and the quality of
the data said because there's some so it
was like reddit threads that had they
were operated highly so there's already
some weak supervision on a very large
data set that people don't often talk
about
I find it today we have maturing
processes to managing cold things like
get right version control took us a long
time to evolve the good processes I
remember when my friends and I were
emailing each other C++ files and email
you know but then we had was the CVS
subversion get maybe something else in
the future um we're very immature in
terms of Susa managing data and think
about how to clean tater and how the
soft I'm very hot messy data problems I
think there's a lot of innovation there
to be has still I love the idea that you
were versioning through email I'll give
you one example um when we work with
manufacturing companies is not at all
uncommon for there to be multiple APIs
that disagree of each other right and so
we were doing the work in visual
inspection we will you know take say a
plastic cards and show to one inspector
and the inspector sometimes very
opinionated there go clearly that's the
defector scratch under set to a
government check this part take the same
parts of different inspector different
very opinionated clearly the scratches
small is fine
don't throw it away you're gonna make us
use and then sometimes you take the same
plastic part show it to the same
inspector in the afternoon and I suppose
in the morning and very affinity go in
the morning to say clearly is okay in
the afternoon equally confident clearly
this is a defect and so what does the
i-team supposed to do if if sometimes
even one person doesn't agree with
himself or herself in the span of a day
so I think these are the types of them
very practical very messy data problems
that that you know that my teams wrestle
with in the case of large consumer
Internet companies we have a billion
users you have a lot of data you don't
worry about they just take the average
it kind of works but in a case of other
industry settings we don't have big data
if just a small data very small data
says maybe 100 defective parts um or a
hundred examples of a defect if you have
only 100 examples these little labeling
errors you know if 10 of your hundred
labels aren't wrong that actually is 10%
it is that has a big impact so how these
cleaned is up what
you supposed to do this is an example of
the of the types of things that my
team's did this is a landing I example
are wrestling with 2d was small data
which comes up all the time once you're
outside consumer internet yeah that's
fascinating so then you invest more
effort and time in thinking about the
actual labeling process what are the
labels what are the how our
disagreements resolved in all those
kinds of like pragmatic real world
problems that's a fascinating space yeah
I find it actually when I'm teaching at
Stanford I increasingly encourage
students at Stanford to try to find
their own project for the end of term
project rather than just downloading
someone else's nicely clean data set
it's actually much harder if you need to
go and define your own problem to find
your own data set rather than you go to
one of the several good websites very
good websites with with creams scopes
data sets that you could just work on
you